in a quiet corner outside the barracks
the joy of our family reunited even
though it's just for a few minutes
eight-year-old timothy carrying
prosthetic spare parts for his father
who likes to be called sailor blow by
the mind russian mind
sailor lost his left leg two years ago
when he was in the ukrainian marines he
rejoined the army a few days ago
timothy is not fully aware of the scale
of the russian onslaught because his
mother doesn't let him watch the news
i didn't feel comfortable at first
especially sleeping in the corridor but
i'm getting used to it school stopped so
now i spend my days in the corridor
doing nothing watching videos on the
phone and reading books sometimes but
today we will go to help the volunteers
civilians from all walks of life are
pitching in supporting soldiers like
timothy his father and providing
assistance to ukrainians fleeing kharkiv
or southern ukraine
the volunteers are frantic as they grasp
the enormity of the russian assault on
their country
among them natalia
she usually manages a shoe company but
is now putting together kits containing
basic necessities
people need everything clothes hygiene
goods shaving kits toothpaste and
toothbrushes they're coming here without
anything their homes are destroyed so
all they have is the clothes they're
wearing
dinipro has so far remained safe but
this city is bracing itself
public shelters are being prepared all
over the city this is the underground of
a movie theater that was built in the
1950s when ukraine was part of the
soviet union and already then it was
designated as a bomb shelter
during that cold war era the stated
threat was from western powers it's
stuffy with poor ventilation but it will
have to do
the city is under a night curfew sailor
tells me is to prevent the possibility
of russian agents carrying out acts of
subversion
and despite his handicap he says he will
fight to the bitter end
he believes russia's ambitions
are far greater than ukraine
if you look at history starting from
transnistria in moldova
georgia and then donbass he is
protecting his borders with the help of
the so-called self-proclaimed republics
i have to protect my home and my family
because people like me have little
chance to survive in the case of a
russian invasion here many in danipa are
wondering what president vladimir
putin's plans are for the city
with the russian army advancing from the
south and north many believe the quiet
they have now could soon be broken
hamid al-jazeera dinipra in eastern
ukraine
[Music]
france's finance minister has declared
an all-out economic and financial war
against russia but the thing that's not
under international sanctions for now
anyway is russian oil the world's third
largest producer and the other members
of opec plus have decided to stick with
a plan to raise output by 400 000
barrels a day in april gradually
returning to pre-pandemic levels us
benchmark crude oil is at a seven year
high at nearly 110 dollars a barrel
that's despite additional supply being
released by the us and other uh iaea
countries the u.s wanted actually a
bigger uh hike in order to limit
inflation consumer prices across the
eurozone increased by a record 5.8 let's
go live now to the new york stock
exchange al jazeera's gabe elizondo is
uh there uh stocks up what
two thirds of a percent on the day off
their earlier highest gabe what's
happening there right now
yeah the market seemed to be rebounding
after dropping about two percent here uh
in the united states on tuesday so the
market seems to be stabilizing somewhat
at least for
the morning here in uh in new york the
big question is oil and that's what
everyone is watching very closely as you
mentioned oil prices jumping to about
113 dollars a barrel at one point
but let's put this a little bit in
context here this is a very critical
moment for the oil markets and in other
geopolitical uncertainty we've seen in
the past past years and decades we've
seen oil prices spike that's not
particularly unusual what is unusual
about this time according to analysts is
two things very unique are happening
number one is these sanctions that have
been levied against russia by dozens of
countries in europe and the united
states and elsewhere
are devastating and while these
sanctions do not directly keyword
directly target the uh energy sector in
russia they indirectly
uh are affecting it so how do you get
oil out of russia uh are big key
questions now so these sanctions are
having an effect on oil prices even
though the sanctions don't directly uh
affect the the the oil market in russia
number two is these sanctions are
against not just any country but against
the world's
second or third largest producer and
exporter of oil and that's russia so
take those two things combined and
that's why you're seeing prices of oil
surge and according to analysts here in
the united states that follow this
closely
they are saying they foresee potentially
a day where oil very soon could reach
125
to even 135 or 45 dollars a barrel now
uh last thing i'll say is to keep in
context here is that the united states
and 30 other allies announced they're
going to release 60 million barrels of
oil from the strategic reserves that
sounds like a lot that is a lot but it
was not nearly enough to bring down the
prices that's because the world consumes
about a hundred billion a hundred
million barrels of oil a day so you can
see that the predicament that many
countries can oil produce oil consuming
countries are in right now trying to
bring these prices down all right gabe
many thanks indeed al jazeera's gabriel
elizondo they're live at the new york
stock exchange uh marusha attacking is
an international oil and energy
consultant he was a research officer at
opec
in vienna and joins us now live from
london good to have you with us so
before we talk about the politics of oil
i just want to clear something up we all
know that the price of gas is rising at
the petrol pump where we're going to
fill up the car what do we actually mean
when we talk about the price of oil
the price of oil is the price of crude
oil which is was announced now 100 and
it was actually 113 dollars a barrel and
could go to higher and higher but when
the in the united states consumers talk
about gas is the petrol is the gasoline
and that of course the petroleum product
and that is subjected to local market
conditions but
oil is an integrated international
market
and although there are variations within
each country on the product market
overall
even if there is enough oil in the
united states when the price goes up in
the international market
the price goes up in the gasoline pumps
in the united states as well so that is
answer to your question on what we mean
by the price of of oil and the oil
market okay and as you said there was a
it was sold by your colleague
by the commentator is very elegantly
that there is a fear that there could be
shortage of oil being traded around the
world
because of embargoes sanctions on u.s
ships and those who trade in u.s and u.s
banking and financials and so on at
present there is no
cut-off of of oil from exports from
russia but there is a fear for it and
always in the oil market the fear and
perception
of shortage or extra or excess oil
always affects the market the price
immediately all right so has done today
so they may be panicking about nothing
at all it may it may not actually come
to fruition but if it did if uh
sanctions were placed against russian
oil exports russian oil companies
could the world survive without russian
oil given that it's the world's what
third largest producer
well it depends on how much it's a seven
million barrels that's a rough number of
uh
of russian oil exports and this cannot
be replaced
as you heard international energy agency
using the strategic petroleum reserve
coordinated policy
of north america europe
japan and so on it's only 60 million
barrels that they are getting out of
there so it cannot be replaced
so the prices will go up higher and
higher it could boot as was mentioned
hundred twenty hundred thirty you know
we have experienced hundred forty seven
dollars a barrel the price of oil in
july if i remember 2014
at that time there were other reasons
there was actual supply shortage et
cetera et cetera so if there is shortage
the prices will okay so why hasn't opec
plus uh stepped up production why is it
sticking its plan to gradually raise
output to just four hundred thousand
barrels a day uh by april uh to
pre-pandemic levels
expect that there are a number of
reasons one is that the opaque is
together with the red with the so-called
opec plus none of the countries the
major one is
russia
in fact
the deputy chairman of the opec plus
meeting
committee or coordination group
is the deputy prime minister of russia
and so the opec members the major one
the kingpin being
saudi arabia they have been working
together with mr novak from russia for
the last two three years and that led
because let's forget there was a excess
oil the price of oil collapsed in half
in 2020 because of kobe then so on and
the world was pleading opec plus the its
opec plus and so on to do something and
they did they reduce supply to get the
price up now of course is the other way
around so in response for the increase
in demand after that priceless
oil price shortage or oil price collapse
they decided about a year ago this group
that every month they would increase
four hundred thousand dollars per day
their production
and their meeting today they decided to
continue that annual that monthly
increase again and that will go on that
would start from the beginning of april
and then by may and so on they may have
a different policy so so it is
coordinated between this group and so
based on that they didn't want to rock
the boat what they statement was they
believed there was enough supply at
present in the market and as i explained
the high price is because of a fear of
shortage so they said we don't want to
flood the market there is no need to
increase beyond the 400 000
okay it's been really good to talk to
you sir um i've learned a lot many
thanks maruchi tuck in there in london